pour mieux prévenir la maladie on
s'efforce depuis des années de la
diagnostiquer dès l'enfance
aujourd'hui on fait mieux dès la
septième semaine de grossesse les
techniques nouvelles permettent de
déceler les maladies de l'embryon le
comité national de l'enfance consacré
aujourd'hui une journée d'étude à ces
méthodes que nous explique lucie se
bouclent cette femme enceinte va
accoucher en toute tranquillité car elle
sait qu'elle va mettre au monde une
fille elle a déjà un garçon myopathe une
maladie génétique dont seuls les garçons
sont atteints s'il a pu entamer et
poursuivre sa grossesse c'est grâce à
une nouvelle technique de diagnostic
prénatal qui lui a permis de connaître
le sexe de son enfant à cette semaine de
grossesse donc dans les délais légaux de
l'avortement dans son cas on cherchait
le sexe dans d'autres cas la technique
est employée pour rechercher une
anomalie génétique elle est toujours la
même
le prélèvement sous échographie d'un
fragment du tissus qui entourent
l'embryon qu'on appelle le trophoblaste
un geste rapide qui ne nécessite ni
anesthésie ni hospitalisation par
l'orifice externe et col d'utérus
on la voit arriver ici à travers l'école
sur le l'écran les peaux grasses
elle peut être très très doucement
se dirige
vers l'autre oblast vers l'endroit où il
est plus épais la page s'ouvre continue
à avancer se referment et retiré pour
l'emmener un petit morceau de
trophoblaste le trophoblaste le voici
c'est le tissu nourricier de l'embryon
il a exactement les mêmes cellules que
lui par la suite il formera le placenta
à l'origine les premières cellules se
divisent les unes vont former le
troupeau place du placenta et l'autre le
foetus est donc les cellules du
trophoblaste représente exactement
patrimoine génétique du foetus et à
partir du moment où on peut analyser
rentrer dans ma part l'étude de ce
patrimoine génétique
c'est bien c'est comme si l'on étudié le
futur humaine dans un second temps ce
fragment du tissu est analysée soit
comme ici pour déterminer le sexe de
l'enfant soit pour détecter une anomalie
décelable tôt dans la grossesse maison
peut diagnostiquer ces maladies qu'à la
condition de connaître précisément le
gène responsable de la section
ce qui est loin d'être toujours le cas
pour le moment on sait déceler quelques
anomalies sanguines les on espère
prochainement parvenir à détecter par
cette méthode
l'hémophilie et la myopathie par exemple
jusqu'à présent une soixantaine de
diagnostic ont été effectués ainsi en
france il semble que le risque de
provoquer une fausse couche soit très
faible et cette technique ne peut être
proposée actuellement qu'aux couples
ayant un risque sur quatre d'avoir un
enfant anormal risque à apprendre je
n'avais pas d'autre solution un mois
d'attenté les synthèses et qu'il en est
eu une grossesse de trois mois et demi
voire de quatre mois lorsqu'il donne le
résultat
et qu'est ce que vous attendiez de ce
diagnostic de ce prélèvement si précoce
pas déjà d'une rapidité pour pouvoir
agir parce que vos mains l'avortement
s'étaient faites plus tôt possible au
temps de faire et puis de savoir le plus
tôt possible de sexe de l'enfant
c'est un sexe masculin moi je me serais
fait avorter talent et nexity une petite
fille que j'attends de ce réseau rue
prélever du trophoblaste n'est plus un
problème reste donc aux biologistes à
mettre au point des sondes pour les
maladies héréditaires les plus graves et
les plus invalidantes
donc vous voyez tout à fait comparable